J Je m'entretiens avec les
papanélistes Chantal Hébert,
MiMichel C. Auger et
AlAlec Castonguay; bonjour.
- - (ensemble): Bonjour.
- - C'était le discours inaugurl
àà Québec, aujourd'hui.
NoNous sommes à la veille de ce
didiscours. Je vous fais entende
unun petit extrait de cette
pupublicité publie Monsieur
LeLegault aujourd'hui.
- - On va finir de remplir
nonos engagements, mais on va
auaussi lancer des grands
chchantiers de changement.
ToTout votre gouvernement va ête
momobilisé pour changer ce qui
dodoit être changé. Et on va
lele faire ensemble. À demain.
- - À demain! Alec Castonguay
c'c'est un exercice un peu comme
unun plan de travail pour sa
dedernière année.
- - L'objectif est de sortir dea
gegestion de la pandémie qui
acaccapare le gouvernement depus
plplus d'un an et demi et qui
acaccapare aussitôt l'agenda du
gogouvernement. Donc, on parle
mamais c'est aussi parce que tot
lele reste est un peu mis en
veveilleuse et avant les
élélections, on est capable de
momontrer qu'on peut parler
d'autres sujets : environnement,
gagarderie, santé. Pas uniquemet
dede la COVID mais de la santé n
gégénéral parce que le réseau
crcraque de partout. On l'a vu
avavec les vaccinations
obobligatoires que le problème e
pépénurie de main-d'oeuvre est
tetellement important que là, ça
fufuit de partout. Donc, on esse
dede montrer que le gouvernemena
enencore du ressort un peu dansa
dedernière année et qu'il peut
prprésenter des nouveautés des
chchoses intéressantes parce qun
veveut arriver en élection avecn
pepeu le vent dans le dos.
- - Est-ce un exercice qui est
vrvraiment incontournable? Quand
onon veut changer les perspectis
susurtout et changer d'air?
- - C'est pas incontournable. M.
CoCouillard n'avait pas fait de
didiscours inaugural ami mandatu
plplus tard dans le mandat. Ce e
çaça montre je pense qu'il y a e
crcrainte niveau du gouvernement
quque toutes sortes de dossiers,
plplaces en garderie notamment l
y y a beaucoup de parents qui
chcherchent encore des places en
gagarderie. Le système de santé
ququi craque de partout et qui
popourrait encore présenter des
pépénuries avec des chirurgies
rereportées à cause de la pénure
dede main-d'oeuvre cette fois-cà
cacause de la COVID : il y a des
chchoses comme ça qui ne sont ps
agagréables à avoir sur le dos
ququand on s'en va en élection.
DoDonc, il veut donner clairemet
l'l'image d'un gouvernement qui
didit : nous savons où sont les
prproblèmes et on va s'en occup.
- - On a vu, au fil des plus
rérécentes élections fédérales t
prprovinciales, qu'il ne faut ps
atattendre une récompense de fin
d'd'année pour la gestion de la
papandémie. Les électeurs ne
veveulent pas savoir ce que vous
avavez fait pour ils veulent
sasavoir ce que vous allez faire
etet vous. On imagine qu'à
l'l'automne prochain on pourrait
êêtre un peu hagard par rapportà
lala pandémie. Donc l'utilité de
cece genre de discours, c'est
d'd'imposer même au gouvernement
lului-même une espèce de
didiscipline et de dire : voicie
susur quoi on va travailler au
cocours de la prochaine année. t
pupuis, il devrait y avoir danse
didiscours des choses qui ne sot
papas dans le paysage parce qu'l
fafaut aussi donner aux électeus
dedes raisons de vouloir que ces
gegens-là continuent leur trava.
- - Une synthèse de ce qu'il vet
fafaire. La fermentation à Ottaa
a,a, pour certains, tarder maise
ququi va retarder encore plus le
cacabinet. Mardi prochain, il y
auaura un nouveau gouvernement
avavec des ministres assermenté.
C'C'est une évidence selon vouse
didire qu'il aura de gros
chchangements que ce ne sera pas
quque de trois personnes qui vot
chchanger de place?
- - Presque impossible que ce st
mimineur avec deux ou trois
ajajustements dans la marge pare
quque quand on commence, on sait
ouoù on commence mais on ne sait
papas où on termine dans ce gene
d'd'exercice. Il faut que Justin
TrTrudeau maintienne la parité.l
s's'y est engagé. Donc, qu'il
reremplace quatre femmes et fase
unune place au conseil des
miministres pour un ministre de
l'l'Alberta. Quand vous
adadditionnez tout cela, ça peut
dodonner des changements et aprs
totout ça, c'est logistique. C't
unun exercice arithmétique. C'et
lele message que le premier
miministre veut envoyer sur ce
ququ'il entend faire de ce qui
popourrait être son dernier
mamandat. Alors, on le sait, la
DéDéfense nationale, peut être n
prproblème. Est-ce qu'on veut
gagarder le même leader du
gogouvernement en chambre? Est-e
quque Pablo Rodriguez peut rest?
IlIl y a des cartouches qui ont
étété brûlées en fin de sessiont
cece n'est pas l'emploi le plus
agagréable au sein du conseil ds
miministres. Quand ça commence,a
fifinit par donner plus de
chchangement qu'est-ce qu'on
auaurait pu l'imaginer.
- - Michel, est-ce que ça a été
trtrop long ou c'est l'autre sut
dodont on va parler après mes le
reretour en chambre qui est peu-
êêtre trop long. Mais pour créer
unun conseil des ministres, c'et
ququand même plus long que
d'd'habitude.
- - Oui, ça veut dire que on a
prprobablement un assez gros
chchangement de cabinet, même si
lele ministre des Finances reste
llà il avait ex-première ministe
ququi est en selle. Ailleurs ça
ririsque de changer.
EsEssentiellement, pour les
raraisons données par Chantal.
QuQuand vous commencez à
dédétricoter un conseil des
miministres, il faut avoir la
paparité, aller chercher minists
enen Alberta qui doit
nénécessairement être un homme a
dedevient compliqué. Tous les
miministres détestent ça. Mais
dadans ce cas-ci, ça ne peut pas
êêtre une petite affaire. On aua
prprobablement un cabinet plus
imimportant avec des ministres e
plplus pour permettre justement
d'd'avoir la parité. À ce momen-
llà, ça fait des vagues ça fait
dedes changements.
- - Si on passe tout de suite au
2222 novembre parce que vous alz
nonous entendre sur le cabinet.e
2222 novembre, c'est le retour n
chchambre. N'est-ce pas tard?
- - Oui, c'est un peu tard. Si n
reregarde les anciens
gogouvernements lorsqu'ils sont
foformés, c'est assez tard quand
mmême dans la moyenne.
NoNormalement, ce type de délaie
plplus de deux mois réservés à s
gogoûts nouveaux gouvernement qi
s's'installent et qui n'ont pas
étété au pouvoir depuis bien des
anannées et qui doivent tous crr
d'd'un seul coup avec des années
dede Stephen Harper donc pour un
gogouvernement qui en est à son
trtroisième mandat, ça aurait pu
êêtre début novembre. EsEst-ce e
çaça veut dire que Justin Trudeu
n'n'a pas envie d'aller en chame
etet d'affronter les partis
d'd'opposition, de faire des
cocompromis et d'avancer des
prprojets de loi? Peut-être. Oue
reremaniement ministériel et la
crcréation de son cabinet sera
susuffisamment important pour
lalaisser à ces nouveaux minists
lele temps d'apprendre leur
dodossier avant d'aller en chame
d'd'affronter les positions. Aii
ilils pourront mettre leleur
prpriorité en ordre d'avoir une
séséance d'information avec les
fofonctionnaires, dire tout ça.
PePeut-être que ça présage un
cacabinet qui sera vraiment
didifférent et que ce délai sert
jujustifié. On verra.
- - Je suis d'accord jusqu'à un
cecertain point. J'ai vu que la
momoyenne est de 70 jours. La
momoyenne est fondée sur l'époqe
ouoù il fallait prendre le train
susur quatre jours pour venir à
OtOttawa. Alors, on passe sur la
momoyenne puisque nous ne sommes
papas dans ce scénario. C'est dc
plplus long dans cette équation.
JeJe suis curieuse de voir que
MoMonsieur Trudeau va tenter de
s's'arrimer plus solidement un
paparti d'opposition plutôt quee
rerevivre... le printemps derni,
çaça n'a pas été drôle à la
chchambre des communes. Si on
rereprend là où on a laissé, je
vavais vous dire qu'on va être
cocontent qu'il parte à Noël.
- - L'Alberta! Expliquait-moi ce
ququ'on doit comprendre de ce
réréférendum qui a lieu
auaujourd'hui. Les Alberta invoe
auaujourd'hui entre autres sur a
ququestion principale qui porte
susur la péréquation. Est-ce qun
dedevrait changer la constitutin
cacanadienne pour ne plus obligr
ceces paiements de péréquation.n
vovoit le texte de la question
icici.
QuQu'est-ce que ça donne si le i
l'l'emporte ce soir comme c'est
prprévu?
- - Pas grand-chose. Personne a
bebesoin d'une seule province pr
quque la péréquation continue.
C'C'est une prérogative du
gogouvernement fédéral du Canada
etet non d'une seule province.
D'D'autre part, il n'y a pas de
mamasse critique provincial. Vos
n'n'avez pas entendu le premier
miministre conservateur dire que
JaJason Kenney est sur une belle
pipiste et que s'il obtient le
ououi, en appui. C'est un peu un
cocoup d'épée dans l'eau dans le
memeilleur scénario. C'est censé
dodonné... Jason Kenney lui-même
didit que ça ne va pas donner ce
ququ'il demande mais ça va lui
dodonner un levier. Je ne suis s
coconvaincu que c'était vraiment
unune bonne idée aujourd'hui,
c'c'est dur à dire.
- - Est-ce que vraiment ça va
obobliger le fédéral à négocier
unune telle chose et même si le
réréférendum est gagné de très
hahaut?
- - Théoriquement, oui. Donc c't
lele renvoi sur la cessation du
QuQuébec qui disait quelque part
quque référendum équivaut à une
obobligation de négocier. Aucune
prprovince n'a fait ça depuis ce
tetemps-là, de Québec sur la
sosouveraineté. Son sort des
enenjeux constitutionnels. Là-
dedessus, donc, techniquement, l
popourrait y aller mais est-ce
ququ'il va gagner son référendu?
ChChantal les 10 alors qu'il étt
plplus populaire au Canada c'étt
plplus facile mais avec 20 %
d'd'appui, ce n'est pas sûr qu'l
gagagne et ce sera probablement
fafaire pouyet pouet à la fin.
- - Michel a raison. Normalemen,
unune promesse constitutionnelle
ouou modifier la constitution ac
unun référendum en bonne et due
foforme, jugement de la cour
susuprême d'Ottawa devrait
nénégocier. Mais il y a beaucoup
dede petits caractères qui ne st
papas explicites dans ce type de
nénégociation. Quel sera le taux
dede participation? N'a pas eu e
vévéritable campagne fétide
réréférendaire avec un camp du i
etet un camp du non. À Calgary,n
vovoit Amélie avait même pas une
liliste électorale pour qui elle
esest votée. On se croise les
dodoigts pour que les gens
n'n'aillent pas voter deux ou
trtrois fois. Ce qu'on disait sr
lele terrain. Dans un processus
cocomme celui-là qui est vraimet
trtrès mal encadré, est-ce que e
féfédéral va reconnaître les
rérésultats et dire qu'elle a
l'l'obligation de négocier? Je
susuis loin d'être certain de ç.
EÉtant donné que d'autres
prprovinces sont fortement
dédésaccord avec l'idée de Jason
KeKenney, il y aura peut-être ue
niniveau de négociation quand il
ététait populaire mais si persoe
nene le suit, je ne pense pas qe
çaça va donner qu'aux résultats.
- - On demande aussi s'ils sont
popour ou contre le changement
d'd'heure.
- - Mais si on veut d'une provie
ququi fasse un abonnement
coconstitutionnel, elle n'a qu'à
lele faire adopter dans sa
lélégislature et lancer la balle
etet lhorloge pour trois ans. Ça
n'n'est pas nécessaire de fairen
réréférendum en maintenant que e
chchangement d'heure. Cette
tetechnologie existait avant le
jujugement de la cour suprême. t
çaça va continuer d'exister. Ily
a a un pouvoir d'initiative
prprovinciale en affaire
d'd'amendement constitutionnel.
- - Oui, mais le résultat...
- - oui mais on n'a pas besoin
d'd'avoir un mandat. On peut alr
àà la législature et dire : je
veveux que l'on amende le Sénat.
LLà, on peut voir si on arrive u
cocompte et si cette province ft
l'l'unanimité sur trois ans.
- - Bonne chance. Quelqu'un a dà
esessayé. Combien de restes de
tetemps? Trois minutes. Colin
PoPowell, Michel, je commence ac
vovous. C'est un personnage
fafascinant. En 2003 il a dû fae
dedes cauchemars pendant pendant
dadans plusieurs années pour
dédéfendre l'indéfendable qu'il
ininvasion en Irak avec des
prpreuves ténues qui reposaient
susur à peu près rien. Comment
vovous résumez les personnes
ââgées?
- - J'étais dans la salle cette
jojournée-là. Je voyais un homme
ququi n'avait pas envie d'être .
VoVous avez montré des photos
aéaériennes de base militaire en
didisait que les camions à la
poporte et un camion d'une
mamanufacture le gaz s sarin des
chchoses comme ça. Ça pouvait ou
trtrousser un camion de gravell.
OnOn ne pouvait pas le voir d'ue
tetelle distance. L'épreuve
n'n'était pas convaincant pour
lului-même. Ça paraissait. Il a
totoujours dit que c'était une
ttâche sur son dossier. Il a dit
apaprès ça que on l'a envoyé pae
quque ça pourrait lui donner
ququelques points de popularité.
IlIl se casse la gueule, ce sert
bibien aussi. Il n'était pas du
grgroupe.
- - Je suis convaincu qu'il savt
ququ'on parlerait de cet épisode
lolors de sa vie qui d'autre pat
esest nettement plus intéressant
quque cet épisode là et il savat
ququ'on n'en parlerait
auaujourd'hui. Mais de façon
gégénérale, c'est un personnage
tototalement marquant. Et on pae
totoujours de Barack Obama mais
CoColin Powell fait parti de cee
hihistoire-là.
- - Il aurait pu, en 2016, ça a
papassé proche... en 96, pardon.
- - Il était à ce moment-là
auauréoler du succès de la
prpremière guerre en Irak. Il et
dedevenu une figure connue
efeffectivement, pour bien des
afafro-américain c'était un
pepersonnage en Ascension. Il
pepeut-être pu devenir le premir
afafro-américain à la tête des
EÉtats-Unis avant Barack Obama.
CÇa ne s'est pas produit. Si
l'l'histoire était à refaire il
n'n'aurait peut-être pas autant
didilapidé le capital de sympate
etet politique autour de la guee
enen Irak et aurait probablement
ddû démissionner à ce moment-là
s's'il trouve que l'épreuve est
ininsuffisante plutôt qu'aller u
vivisage du monde et justifie ce
prproduit. Mais il était trop
tatard. Il le savait, que le jor
dede sa mort ce serait un reproe
dadans une carrière qui était
plplutôt exemplaire pour à peu
prprès tout le reste. Y comprisa
mamanière dont il s'est opposé x
rérépublicains de Donald Trump n
didisait qu'il ne reconnaissait
plplus son parti. Après de coure
popour le faire. Il l'a fait. Il
n'n'avait pas eu le même couragà
l'l'époque lors de la guerre en
IrIrak.
- - Il a rompu avec les
rérépublicains après l'attaque u
CaCapitole. Mais effectivement l
n'n'est pas né avec une cuillère
d'd'argent dans la bouche. Il
vevenait du Bronx.